[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
noi siamo i forti fingers come potete
vedere dagli strumenti che abbiamo qui
con noi siamo corso di chitarra questo
di chitarristi acustici
nell'immaginario comune la chitarra
acustica e spesso vista solo come un
semplice strumento d'accompagnamento
specialmente per la voce noi invece con
le nostre chitarre vogliamo fare una
piccola orchestra mescolando le melodie
le armonie e ritmi le armonizzazioni il
brano che vi faremo senza dirlo ora
riunisce un po tutto questo che vi ha
spiegato adesso buon ascolto
[Musica]
no
il tema di oggi si intitola complexity
la complessità e prima di arrivare noi
ci siamo chiesti cosa fosse per noi la
complessità come si potesse spiegare ad
un pubblico
inizierei col dire che complessità in
musica non è quasi mai sinonimo di
bellezza o meglio ci vuole molta
esperienza per riuscire a suonare delle
cose complesse con leggerezza e allo
stesso tempo e complesso scrivere
comporre qualcosa di musikalmente
interessante ma che risulti semplice e
diretto all'ascolto
fare cose semplici è la vera complessità
specialmente quando si hanno a
disposizione quattro chitarre e quindi
si ha la possibilità di sperimentare
tantissime combinazioni sonore come
diceva un mio caro amico
la semplicità è una dura conquista per
questo motivo a volte è necessario fare
un passo indietro mettersi nei panni
dell'ascoltatore di quelli che noi
definiamo i non addetti ai lavori perché
solitamente sono le persone che
riescono a individuare maggiormente
quelli che sono i punti di forza e di
debolezza di una canzone da un punto di
vista emotivo che quello più importante
l'emozione è l'unica è la vera parte
della musica che arriva a chi ascolta
tutto il resto è solamente un contorno
ovviamente indispensabile
il prossimo brano che suoneremo
abbraccia appieno questa filosofia della
semplicità infatti sentirete che si può
raggiungere un run giamento
apparentemente complesso dell'unione ed
alla distribuzione di quattro parti
musicalmente molto semplici come in una
piccola orchestra
ogni parte alla stessa importanza ed è
complementare alle altre
per capire come lavoriamo i nostri
arrangiamenti bisogna introdurre alcuni
concetti fondamentali della lingua
musicale la musica si compone infatti
essenzialmente di quattro elementi e
questi quattro elementi sono la melodia
l'armonia il ritmo e la forma ora
sappiamo tutti che cos'è una melodia ma
se volessimo provare a dare una
definizione e fare un parallelismo con
la pittura
beh diremmo che la melodia è il soggetto
di un ritratto provate ad immaginare la
gioconda ecco la monna lisa e la nostra
melodia che cosa invece l'armonia
ci sono tante definizioni più o meno
tecniche ma a nostro parere quella più
semplice è anche quella più efficace
l'armonia e lo sfondo provate a
immaginare se la monna lisa invece di
essere ambientata in un contesto
naturalistico fosse ambientata
all'interno di un osteria il significato
del dipinto sarebbe completamente
diverso per capire invece cosa sono
il ritmo e la forma è forse più produrre
o fare un parallelismo con il cinema il
ritmo e la velocità con cui le cose
accadono e le scene si susseguono una
dopo l'altra mentre la forma è il modo
in cui una scena iniziale una situazione
iniziale evolve e arriva ad una
conclusione
ecco già con questi pochi elementi molto
semplici possiamo prepararci ad
ascoltare il prossimo brano in modo più
consapevole provate a individuare chi
tra di noi sta suonando la melodia chi
sta suonando l'armonia che struttura il
brano vi presentiamo il nostro medley di
celebri temi disney
buon ascolto
[Musica]
nell'arrangiamento che avete sentito nel
primo brano c'è da sottolineare anche la
parte percussiva e ritmica che abbiamo
inserito che dal brano un sapore più
etnico e tribali che spesso caratterizza
un genere musicale da un altro a seconda
delle zone e delle culture la
composizione in generale che sia di un
arrangiamento di una cover soprattutto
di un brano originale è un procedimento
che va avviato e curato in vari aspetti
quello teorico e matematico quello
emozionale ed espressivo e poi quello
che riguarda le esecuzioni finale
sostanzialmente si tratta di dare alla
musica una veste o più come nel prossimo
ed ultimo brano bohemian rhapsody che
suoneremo che incomincia con una parte
una ballata lenta introduttiva che
sfocia poi in una parte più paris tica
più veloce le nostre parti di chitarra
si incastrano vanno riprodurre le
sezioni delle voci e del pianoforte e
con questo vi ringraziamo per
l'attenzione e speriamo di vedervi ai
nostri concerti
[Musica]